what do you think about I don't know how
old you are I don't know if you share
you're 40. okay so I'm 43 so we're right
there so we grew up in a time where
technology wasn't everywhere you know
you didn't have the cell phone you
didn't have the social media it was much
healthier I would argue and much like
the dating scene was much easier to
navigate but
that's my opinion anyway but
are you concerned at all about a dating
culture young people in particular that
are now meeting each other online more
than in person that don't have those
skills of like being able to walk up to
somebody and ask them out it's like
everything is texting they're shielded
behind this phone and oftentimes you're
dealing with a whole bunch of strangers
you don't even get to meet until
a certain a certain way in are you
concerned at all about this new culture
of Instagram of tick tock of Tinder and
leave and losing a lot of just what we
used to do we used to just go to a party
and you'd meet up with someone you'd
walk up to them you'd ask them out you'd
get to know them in person it was just
how much for me a much healthier
personal eye contact human feel to it is
that were you well you have to see the
good points of that of that social media
like the Tinder gives you a much more
bigger uh it gives you more people to be
able to be in contact with isn't that
good though well not necessarily bad
it's not necessarily bad because you
always have the people around someone
back then dating back then was not
better I'm not gonna say it's better I'm
not gonna see I'm not willing to be like
yeah in the 50th and the 50s for women
no I'm thinking like when we grew up
even even for the 80s I'm not going to
say that it's better but 100. I'm not
gonna say that but
the social media thing and the kids
having that and everything I'm terrified
you've seen Blackberry that [ __ ] oh yeah
for real have I seen it we we're living
some of it we're already in it
that's what I'm saying oh this [ __ ] is
closer than y'all guys think so yeah
whenever the social media thing and
being able to talk to people and stuff
like that is super weird and yes there's
a there's a definitely an issue there
there is there is I got one of my
friends was talking to one of my friends
she has she has a boy
boys 14.
he has a girlfriend a little girlfriend
and stuff and she's like yeah the girl
when she comes to my house she goes
directly in the room she don't talk she
don't say hi I'll be like yo you gotta
break it down and listen uh excuse me
yeah let me talk to you for a second
yeah
um this is my house
when you come in my house you say hi you
come in you come and greet
the owner of the premises that's me but
because of all of this and being
shielded on the wall I'll send you an
emoji no no no no no no no no don't
don't I don't do Emojis for that reason
talk to me
with your words with your emotions what
you think so yes I do absolutely a
hundred percent think there is an issue
I can see the positive but I think
there's more damage than positive to be
honest even the skills that like I think
about when I was in grade school when I
was in sixth grade seventh grade we used
to have these little dances
and you know the guys would have to get
the courage to walk across the dance
floor and ask the girl to dance and I
think all these things
turned boys into men you know they had
to you know they faced rejection in
person not ask somebody out on the phone
and you don't have to look at them you
don't have to face rejection in the same
way but guys in particular I feel like
learned so many important skills from
that time of just having to face someone
face to face for so many things that
they don't have to do now
and the thing about options is I get
what you're saying about you know if you
were living in a small town you know 30
years ago 40 years ago your options were
limited of who you wanted to date maybe
there weren't that many people around
but now Tinder there's so many options
this is a small percentage of my
argument right but I'm just thinking
think about this part though very small
think about it though like the options
sometimes can be like misleading you
think you have all of these options but
you don't really don't mean that you fit
with them it's just able to try it's
like a false sense of security you're
able to travel further and faster
but you lack the genuinity when I feel
like through social media because people
can be someone different through the
phone and you may think you're making a
connection with them and yeah you may
have more reach but you're really
reaching people that aren't authentic so
yeah what would be a pro because you
said there's more cons but what would be
a pro that just reaching more reaching
more people even more being able to sort
out the people not having to go out to
all those dates with all those people
around your play so what you're going to
do you're going to date people at your
work if if not if we take social media
you're gonna people date people at your
work people at church if you go to
church but also you it forces them to
maybe expand but I'm traveling I'm
talking about the cons so once you do
all that you can and you know you date
someone at work it doesn't work [ __ ]
but the reality is for most people that
do a nine to five they spend more time
if they do a normal week they do 40
hours at work and if they don't do more
[ __ ] it's more than 40. so all the
people you're going to meet whether it's
clients or whatever is going to be at
work so let's be honest if so we remove
social media what do we have well you
have come the thing is like what what
you were forced to do then is have more
sense of community you were forced to
like spend more time with your friends
hold those House parties where you were
more interactive in person because we
have this we're lazy we're like oh I can
see you know 50 people in a second here
so I don't need to even be interacting
with them so there's an odd sense of
even though we're connecting technically
with more people we're more isolated
than ever in a way I agree with that but
I I'm just talking about the point yeah
yes that's a pro like I said small part
of my argument here yeah there's more
cons and Pros yeah like I'm just
highlighting everything that's important
and the cons so we have all the black as
little Pros that we have but but at
least they're there did I tell you about
Black Mirror
telling you yeah like that [ __ ]
terrified Gary if you want to watch the
full episode you're going to click right
here and if you want to ask me a
question one on one you want to do a
one-on-one FaceTime with a group of your
friends whatever you want you need to
download manect right now click right
here and let's get talking
[Music]